um Mike Pence a failed former vice
president Mike Pence was interviewed uh
yesterday and he was asked if Trump is
the nominee in 2024 will you vote for
him now remember
trumpists are the people who were
shouting hang Mike Pence on January 6th
Trump is the guy who completely turned
on Pence because Pence wasn't willing
nor Able by the way wasn't willing as
Trump says to do the right thing to try
to steal an election for Trump that he
didn't actually win and here is what
Mike Pence has to say when asked about
this if Donald Trump is the Republican
nominee for president in 2024 will he
vote for him
foreign
[Applause]
well there might be somebody else I'd
prefer more
okay
you know what I can tell you is I'm I
have every confidence that the
Republican party is going to sort out
leadership all my focus has been on the
midterm elections and it'll stay that
way for the next 20 days but after that
we'll be thinking about the future
ours and the Nations and yeah so first
of all he's sort of saying I might be
running I mean to some degree what Mike
Pence is saying is there might be
someone on the ballot I prefer like
myself when he says we're going to be
thinking about our future and the
Nations he's saying I'm going to be
thinking about what I want to do in
2024. regardless of that there are two
interpretations here and they can both
be correct on the one hand
it is very clear that Pence is off the
Trump train and is trying to figure out
the right way to get off uh without
derailing his own political career
that's number one on the other hand
his supporters were saying they wanted
to hang you and the strongest thing
you're willing to say is there might be
someone else who I would prefer more so
you can interpret this however it
strikes your fancy right on the one hand
maybe the strongest anti-trump language
we've heard from any of the major
figures of the Republican party for the
last year and a half on the other hand
his support Trump supporters wanted to
hang this guy and this is all that he's
willing or able to muster up it's all
pretty sad but an indication that the
2024 Republican primary may become very
interesting very quickly right after the
midterms that are now just uh 19 or 20
days away let me know what you think
find me on Twitter at dpacman we'll take
a quick break and be right back